complications a restaurant that sells
food from countries the u.s. is in
conflict with as a way of introducing
people in our city to the viewpoints and
culture of folks who are living in those
countries I think the most important
thing and the whole project is that the
food is really good yes there are
politics related to food but when you
sit down and eat it bypasses your
intellect goes straight to your gut you
like it or you don't it's significant
that this is the one place
Palestine is the one place on earth that
some people in the United States don't
want you to talk about for me I think it
is a public art work you know static
sculptures plunked into public spaces
we're there every day just like the
sculpture is except we talked to you and
feed you and engage in you know
discussions about global politics
one of our employees always says to me
goes like we're just a daily reminder to
people like they walk by
we're a daily reminder of Afghanistan of
Iran of Palestine of these places that
you know oftentimes I think Americans
don't think about on a daily basis